bora lá brincar com pessoal 3211 vai
comer um bombom orientou por lá fala no
centro de maceió
olá pessoal que tem só eu dar que sejam
muito bem vindos
amanhã o bea não estrague mais um vídeo
de microscópio novo vídeo eu disse que
eu espero e descrever sangue mas eu
ainda estou a tentar arranjar esse
material porque é difícil arranjar
espera uma cabala que adhonep mudança
tem câmera procura mais uns dois dias
mas vou conseguir encontrar quatro
locais imagina só ver os bichinhos a
andar entre os primeiros oito muito
pouco mas por enquanto eu vou fazer aqui
uma coisa que faz também pediram muito
comida com um microscópio é conseguir a
meta é um tema muito grande não é porque
a fruta a música aparece há muita coisa
a ver com comida e hoje nós vamos ver um
big mac é num do etanol é separar em
tipos de alimentos porque há muita
comida bem diferente em outros eventos
muita gente por aí diz que é certo é no
gênero que tem muito alto e tem muita
gordura a foca tevez que já encontrou
apenas em junho dentro dos negros do
actor não tinham muita coisa pode
acontecer aqui agora eu tenho medo do
que vão encontrar aqui hoje mas o
estúdio pessoal vamos tentar aqui para
ter uma melhora todos tentaram atingir a
meta do cento e não sem um like the hill
e sem wi fi lhos obras que nós
conseguimos resgatar e pretende debater
a observar as pernas cavalo sangue
instituído em que já tem mais num bom
vamos lá negra isolado tudo hamburgo mas
não posso me candidate trabalha trabalha
e não tem muito o que você acha que tá
bom e tem instalado em que o molho e
queijo pão
321 vai ae
uau comecei muito grande tem tempo tem
um pino um incrível vocês conseguem ver
o equipamento que tem o pão tem gordura
não só textura do pão grupo europeu não
dá mesmo pra mandar pelo vejam só o pão
abrirei one opção agora olha aí o uaw
está por dentro do pão ser coreano
agora sim vamos ter uma partida que tem
muito óbvio que é parte de dentro do pão
é aqui que a empresa não vai não só como
eu com podemos ver isso em todas as
corridas que vir na época a comida tem
alguém toda a comida tem este tipo de
coisas até mesmo a fruta desse banho
juntos vamos lá então passar a carga em
si a carne de vaca é única para 321 vai
não é tão um é igual ao pão com tudo
então é normal que tenha o evento escura
com o carro mais clara e que essas
coisas que ainda não não continuará como
é que torna a pergunta que era tem pelo
pelo mergulho buraco lá dentro
vou tentar curtir um pouco a música que
ver como é ter tudo por dentro ou 31
bairro
o iraque é o que é isto
a textura da carne por dentro é
completamente branca e noé só agora vou
tentar me escalado agora a atriz junto
vai roubo em berlim as coisas tretas
textura bem estranha a cair é bem normal
até é só uma salada
não é então gente poder completamente
textura tipo o que aquilo que é que eu
faço é um bicho é um bicho aqui já
começamos a entrar no pão através de um
hambúrguer para que haja harmonia com as
bolas faltou em cima de uma cebola está
um cubo de cebola ea volta ao museu
municipal do imeq o brutal ataque não
caiu ainda a atriz não vai nunca é igual
tem coisas no meio lucas que eu não sei
o que é o que é isto é pelo gigante que
é interessante é só perde é só uma
janela né
ok achar não falta nada aqui do apop
campeão estão picão é coisa que muita
gente não gosta mas eu adoro pico é
muito bom qual o público também branco
que é que ontem que é transparente
brutal a quem chega pelo hamburg próxima
coisa vai ter então a nossa coca cola
que terá que tem dentro da coca-cola eu
acho que eu vou poder ter um pouco de
coca cola em cima e vamos tentar ver né
porque se eu entrar aqui microscópio não
podem variar toca aí eu já larguei um
pouquinho comer qualquer só vou deixar
aqui coca cola e vamos lá 32 foi vai até
o quarto é o clássico ainda olha a bola
tá bem brilhante pois não só como época
com ela que estava em claro que eu
apontaria luz neto fala muito e dar
mergulhar o microscópio no copo mas com
muito cuidado não pode variar eu não
quero ir 321 vai daí o brilho eu acho
muito estranho não ver nada
estou muito bem é porque é um link e eu
acho que eu vou conseguir ver link de 82
quilos de droga perto henrique e só é
que apresentam eu vou tentar arranjar
isso pois nós vimos melhor a coca-cola
olha tá vamos fazer a nossa batata do
filme a batata deve ter muito
o órgão ainda mais do que o próprio
murilo mas é tão burro e theo boom muito
tocar eu escrevi aqui uma batata assim
esta mas que medina é bem estranho e
vamos lá pessoal 321 vai não só a
quantidade de gordura que a batata tem
meu é completamente branca também mas
tem muito ou eo olha é isso tem bolhas
dólar evoluir só o cérebro microscópio
vocês têm como é também intenção do que
vocês comem é muito melhor então pouca
coisa
as coisas apesar de serem pequenas são
compostas por muita coisa que nós não
conseguimos ver e brutal ontem pelo eu
vou comer uma eu ia comer essa batata
com pelo todo tempo porque eu acho que
eu tentar dominar o nosso mundo só não
como nada tudo o tempo todo na medida
para incluir a montado pela terra ronca
investigar uma batata vamos ver como é
que ela é por dentro é exatamente a
mesma coisa tem óleo ainda mais
branquinha né eu acho que os
microscópios e vou tentar mas não
acredito não acreditem mais pelo livro
começam todos em pelo menos tentar
encontrar outros pelo mais um pelo
núcleo de 53 anos pelo canhoto pela
folha uol
não acredito não acredito nem não vai
perder o olho nu não tá
como é que tem pelo inter só tem só uma
coisa ao longo da nossa vida nossa já
vêm ter comigo milhões de teus milhões
eu inclusive eu e cometeu e não é pra
vocês não querem me dar não só porque
ele é claro o que vão comer mas somente
pelos não perguntarem toda a comida todo
o piauí quer conquistar o nosso mundo é
é a batata frita e agora lá pessoal
vamos ver mais coisas do que eu tenho
mas não saí daqui também o rei da
gordura e também tem muito alto muito
bom o melhor é não só deve ter comido
uns 4872 pelo vai tentar pelo nosso
colega 321 vai
marielson olha aí também tem muito homem
é também outro pelo mais um pelo tudo
tem pêlos não seria pública mas vou
falar sobretudo tempo eo eu acho que
ainda tem mais um jogo do que a própria
batata outro pelo wii câmara para onde
vai mas jogou bem mas não vai continuar
a dormir está em ok go onde por dentro
agora que o meu deus tem muito estranho
igualzinho o pão mas com um pessoal
também agora a sua regular mas que está
na área anexa à uti o meu lado só uma
florista que quer 32 encontrei mais um
pelo suave como colega no ângulo
ei lo não só aí com a capcom street para
fazer nenhum estado comentei o que vocês
acharam que eram gente acharam que é
normal que tanto pela comida contém a
inscrição só como e também mais comidas
para resolver eu acho que já ouvira
chuta mas quem tem mais tempo de comida
que país o fato é que quiserem e não
esqueçam que em princípio amanhã pois
amanhã eu vou postar o vídeo ver o
sangue e esperma campal eu assumir mesmo
que um filme mas há um só quando mesmo
com o vosso pai que vamos tentar chegar
aos 100 milagres neste vídeo é conto com
vocês que como não poderia faltar aqui
do nosso lado vocês vão ter dois filhos
provavelmente não viram o avião mas
vejam a tvs e aqui mais uma vez podem se
inscrever no canal usar é gratificante
bem e se aproximam